كما قلنا بالفعل عدة
مرات، هذا هو أسوأ وقت في اليوم
ليس فقط للمشاة ولكن
أيضًا لحركة المرور واحتمال المخاطرة
هنا هو فقط من خلال تباطؤ السقف
مقارنة بما كان عليه سابقًا ولكن لا تزال
القيادة متقطعة للغاية و  يتجول
حول أي شخص في طريقه دون أي
احترام لهذا الضوء الأحمر هناك يمر
عبر شارع Crossing Hill
وHere Come، تلك الوحدات خلفه،
يمكنك رؤية تلك الوحدة الأساسية
التي تصدق على 605 أو أنا آسف
اه 710  الطريق السريع اه هنا في
الأميال القليلة القادمة
إذا مر عبره،
فلدي بعض المشاكل المختلطة في أذني يا
رفاق،
لا يمكنهم سماعي جيدًا، يا
إلهي، انظروا إلى هذا المشتبه به، إنه
يركض دون أن يركض المسدس دون أن يركض  سوف
يصطحبونه إلى
هنا، إنه الآن في الجادة الغربية، يا
إلهي، يا إلهي، إنه يسير على الأقدام
ويركب سيارة شخص آخر يحاول
سرقة سيارة شخص أجنبي آخر
هناك نذهب
آه آه
واحد على خمسة
آه FM1 على أربعة FM2 قيد التشغيل  خمسة
المجلدات نعم
أه كلاهما يقول إيكوم
أه سلبي انتهى الأمر